welcome to another developer update this
is Jeff I'm one of the guys from the
overwatch team we're here today to talk
to you guys about seasonal content so
seasonal content is something that
Blizzard has been embracing for years if
you go back and look at World of
Warcraft we did our Hallows end event
and the feast of winter veil you've seen
in recent years heroes of the storm and
hearthstone have done seasonal content
as well and it's something we really
wanted to take on and do cool things
with a in overwatch and you might be
asking yourself why what's so cool about
seasonal content and for us when we
think about running a game as a live
service we like to talk about it in
terms of the game having a heartbeat and
the players really feeling the life of
the game and feeling how the game
changes and evolves over time there's
also those cool events that happen in
games if you've been playing them for a
while that it always feels very special
when the event happens again later on so
you know I always think back to when the
pumpkins show up in World of Warcraft
you know Oliver orgrimmar or each year
when we open presents under the tree and
iron forge on the 26 of December it
always just feels like a cool event i
look forward to logging into the game at
that time every year and sort of
experiencing that moment so we want to
do this in overwatch as well we feel
like the world that we're exploring is
really cool we've had this rich universe
that we've been developing and we want
to really create this feel and
excitement for you guys of wow who knows
what Blizzard is going to do next to
really make overwatch feel cool the next
time I log in or what might be around
the corner next month you know what cool
thing might they be cooking up so we
hope that the Summer Games was a big
surprise for all of you I don't know if
anybody saw it coming or was expecting
this but this is the first event that
we're trying and if it's really cool and
successful and you guys like it will
probably have this event run again next
summer as well maybe it'll have some new
content in it as well but this is the
type
thing we want to do where sometimes we
explore very hardcore competitive parts
of the game like you saw us do that in
our June update when we added
competitive play obviously that was
targeted at a certain player type who
wanted that high sense of competition in
the game and something like summer games
is targeted towards more the light side
of overwatch to show you that overwatch
isn't just a fun competitive FPS shooter
but a really cool gaming platform as as
well so you know just to talk about
summer games a little bit there's a lot
of cool stuff going on with it obviously
earning summer games loop boxes is going
to feel very cool we give you one of
these loop boxes just for logging in
during the event as well as a cool
player icon so make sure to log in and
check it out summer games loop boxes all
contain guaranteed one summer games item
and summer games items can range from
legendary skins epic skins we've got
highlight intros we've got cool new
animations for the characters that you
can do while you're a moding we've got
player icons sprays and voice lines and
victory poses of course so all of that
stuff is in the summer games loop boxes
each one you'll guarantee get get one of
those you can by chance get more than
one summer games item in a loop box as
well and the normal loop boxes won't
exist as the event runs so the event
runs roughly for three weeks and during
the event as you level up normally
you'll be getting summer games loop
boxes instead of the the other loop
boxes also in the store the loop boxes
are now replaced with Summer Games loop
boxes as well so this is something new
that we're trying we think it's cool we
want these items to feel extra special
and very rare so we don't want everybody
running around all the time in every
single summer games item and we actually
don't expect that all players will get
all summer games items we want this to
be a thing where six months from now
when the Summer Games has long past that
you look back on somebody who's in that
cool you know summer game
zaria skin and go oh man I can't wait
until next year when the Summer Games
happens maybe I'll be lucky enough to
get that skin so our normal loop box
items eventually you can get all of them
either through playing buying loop boxes
in the store unlocking them through
credits whereas we wanted the seasonal
loop boxes to feel more rare and special
in the items within them to feel more
rare and special so for that reason
they'll only be available for those few
weeks and you won't be able to buy those
items for credits either so hopefully
that will make them feel extra cool when
you have one and hopefully you won't
feel too bad about it if you don't get
one because you know that the event
might happen again next year and then
you'll have another chance the other
cool thing that we're doing with the the
Summer Games events specifically is we
did a custom brawl even though Lucio's
favorite sport in the world is ice
hockey it is summer games so we also
love soccer at blizzard and we really
wanted to do a cool soccer brawl
featuring Lucio and we wanted it to take
place in Rio so Lucio's from Brazil
there's a lot of celebration happening
at this time of year in Rio and we
thought it was a perfect opportunity to
align all these things and feature Lucio
in our soccer event which we're calling
Lucio ball so this is a 3v3 soccer match
basically it lasts very briefly i think
the match length is something like four
minutes and it's a lot of fun it's
completely different than what you're
used to in normal overwatch Lucio's
abilities are roughly the same but a
little bit different you're not trying
to kill each other in this you're
actually just trying to score goals and
we did a lot of things just to make it
you know funner and better there's
there's jump zones where you can jump
really high and fast you can skate on
the walls sort of infinitely at a very
high speed there's cool replays we do
custom cards for it so hopefully you
guys enjoy this a lot of it is a big
experiment for us to see you know is
this fun and cool did we run the event
for the right length of time you know
roughly three weeks and this is
we'll take into future events we have a
lot of ideas about other seasonal
content that we want to make that if
this one is successful or if you guys
have feedback how we could make this one
better will incorporate that in future
events moving forward so that seasonal
content we're working on a ton of other
stuff right now season two for
competitive is one of our main focuses
in development right now we're going to
update you guys on that later I know you
have a lot of questions about that but
for now enjoy the summer games enjoy our
first seasonal event and we look forward
to hearing your feedback thanks again
Oh